so I'm going to be talking about
democratizing and helping content
modeling with transfer learning using
GPUs so one of my colleagues when he saw
the title he was saying why do you want
to put using GPUs in the title and I
don't have any specific slides to say
why using GPUs but it kind of goes into
the theme of democratizing NLP in the
sense that there will be some stuff some
work that will be built using GPUs but
later on the idea is that anybody who
does not have access to GPUs or probably
even doesn't necessarily know how to
build a deep learning model on GPUs
could use the results and that's a rule
so before I go into any technical
details I'd like to kind of introduce
what is check and that's important to
understand the talk overall and why some
of the decisions are the way this
decisions are taken the way it is so
this is like our main website
we cater we're a student hub we cater to
students and provide them help in all
possible directions some of the ones you
can see here are textbook rentals and I
will talk into go into more details
about study map solver as the name
suggests you can go and solve equations
in it
tutors I will again go into some details
writing is another product which
basically gives you writing help it
helps you build bibliography but also
gives you suggestions if your grammar is
wrong so that kind of a product and
internships is another side where
basically students can come and apply
for internships so it's like the whole
package in your student journey from the
beginning to finding a job in some sense
so let me go into some details in to
check tutors and this is a product I had
that I have spent most of my time
working on it is online tutoring on
demand
so a student comes into the site goes in
and basically here you take the subject
you need help with you click find me a
tutor a box opens up in the box the
student it students are strongly advised
to give as details about the questions
as possible sometimes students will say
something like please
help me I have an exam tomorrow those
are really hard to work with but a lot
of the times they will give the details
of the problem they're working on
another product we have is flash tools
as the name suggests these are flash
cards this is a company we acquired
recently some of you might have used
Quizlet which has a lot of flash cards
this is similar and the idea here is
again you go and you type in a term that
you're trying to learn what is metaphase
and then you can either create your own
cards but there are also cards that are
already existing a lot of students would
prefer to find cards that are already
existing to study for their exams and it
has like a wide range of subjects and
finally the product that is like most
popular in some sense is check study
where you can go and ask a question it
could be from a textbook but it could be
also a question that you are asking an
expert on the other side would go and
answer your question so so and in this
case like the question is about
classical thermodynamics what you will
realize is that this is like the data
that I am working with these are Czech
is mainly aportfolio businesses these
are like each of the product are like a
different teams with different
engineering teams distributed across a
globe so sometimes having like being
able to democratize anything is like
very useful at our company so a brief
overview of what I'm going to talk about
democratizing NLP I'll keep coming back
to it throughout the talk transfer
learning I'm going to talk about word
avec which probably most people have
heard about more on sentence and
character and bearings and finally
something that's very popular now word
embeddings in context and finally I will
go into some applications one of the
applications that we have a lot of
success with is knowledge-based creation
which kind of refers to tagging concepts
onto the content that we have it could
be
flashcards it could be questions answers
to questions some dialogue happening
between tutor student chap it could be
anywhere so what do I mean by
democratizing NOP well we have a lot of
text data the first goal is to give some
structure to that text data if you have
a lot of text data sitting somewhere it
doesn't help you in any way unless you
can query it ins in some form so one
goal is not just data scientists but
data analysts should be able to query
the data and get some meaningful results
out of it for instance one of the
product managers once asked me in tutors
is you know how many students are asking
tutors about how does the product work
because you know tutoring is an
expensive platform we would rather have
like a QA system a question support
system that answers that question rather
than students actually asking the tutors
that how does the product work so these
are like very analytics kind of
questions which should be easily
queryable and another very important
part is there may be machine learning
practitioners and when I say machine
learning practitioners I also mean not
people who probably don't have a very
deep knowledge in machine learning maybe
they have like the pipeline with some of
its spark or any other distributed
system and they know how to use like
logistic regression use some features
use logistic regressions and get some
predictions out of it so even those
teams should be able to take advantage
of the rich information that's there in
text data so why transfer learning so
transfer learning gives structure to
unstructured data so it converts texts
into vectors it can be used to solve a
range of problems like summarization
entity recognition tagging keyword
extraction but also any other specific
downstream problem that you might have
and another really nice thing about
transfer learning is that it is doing
auto feature ization of your text that
is as NLP engineer a lot of the times
you kind of have features like do I have
the word we
in this text and then that becomes and
and this is very specific to saying we
would have like a list of words but
these are you don't have to do that kind
of specific feature engineering using
transfer learning so this is a
traditional NLP pipeline and in some
sense a traditional machine learning
pipeline initially you invest in
collecting data luckily we are in a
place where we are collecting data for
all of our products in a lot of details
and data can be in the form of
structured data in the form of text in
the form of images and the next step is
gathering label data so you go to
annotators and you ask them to label
whether your data is of the type you
want gathering label data is a very
expensive step and that is one of the
reasons why I'll talk about like what do
you do when you have small data and then
a lot of feature engineering feature
engineering could be as simple as doing
tf-idf or bag of words like just
counting words but it could also be very
complex domain-specific things where you
look at certain certain occurrences of
part of speech for instance is there a
noun followed by a verb that that kind
of work and then finally you fit a model
it could be the logistic regression or
an SVM or something something more
advanced so using deep learning people
do get rid of a lot of feature
engineering which is great because it
takes a lot of time to do detailed
feature engineering but general deep
learning problems require a lot of data
in most real situations especially when
you are starting a problem
you don't have a lot of data and it's
very hard to go and justify and say hey
I need to collect 10,000 data points
where maybe each of your data points it
takes five minutes to annotate it and in
our case because this is like academic
material you need someone who's an
expert in chemistry you need someone
who's an expert in biology to actually
spend five minutes over a question and
an answer and say give more information
about it so all like in project starts
with very small data
so what is transfer learning so you
start with in in the realm of
traditional machine learning where you
have task one you have some kind of
domain you do all that build a model you
have some results in the other domain
also you repeat the same thing and you
you don't necessarily learn learn from
one task to the other that domain of
transfer learning you learn in one
domain and you gather that knowledge you
store it in some form and then you feed
it to model to to to make predictions in
the other domain and the advantage here
is mainly that in domain two you might
have very little training data whereas
in domain one you might just have a lot
of training data because of how the
problem is set so classic example of
France for learning is computer vision
in computer vision transfer learning has
been used in much details for a while
now especially like the image net models
probably started coming up a few years
ago maybe five years ago or six maybe
more than that six years ago so there
had been like like a set of images which
was a basic classic data set which
everybody could borrow for from and this
particular example it is one of the
cattle competitions where the problem
was to identify diabetic retinopathy and
a lot of the models used the image net
pre-trained features and applied it to
something so different so features would
be trained on flowers or cats or
something completely different and they
would generalize to diabetic retinopathy
which is like a very different field it
has been used and fields of video
recognition human pose detection and
other types of small data and in some
sense the field of computer vision is
way more advanced in the transfer
learning phase compared to natural
language processing so I will I will
start with like this in in transfer
learning I will in NLP I will start with
the simplest example of word avec stuff
how many of you are kind of familiar
with the slides you have looked at okay
so most of the room you know know what's
going on in the realm of where to Veck
you have this example where if you do
King - screen - man you get a woman
basically you have all the vectors which
are contextualized which are
contextualized based on on the text and
it's it's a very shallow network it's
basically one layer and then you have a
softmax you try to predict the next word
or or or something else but basically
your weights come from from just one one
layer this has done pretty well
yeah and in order to use word avec one
thing you can do is just download
Google's pre-trained vectors for a lot
of domains especially for domains like
where you know students or customers are
asking for how does this product work or
other kinds of support something like
pre-trained vectors work really well but
for a lot of the problems that I work on
it's specifically dealing with details
in algebra or details in physics and for
them a lot of times I would train my own
vectors and even that process I mean the
word avec came out about five years ago
there are there's tensorflow there is
like other there's gen same and then
there are other all of the other
packages packages have like some form of
word to Veck you need like so few lines
of codes like this is probably less than
ten lines of code to even generate your
own word vectors which is which is very
convenient and as I go through the next
parts of my talk I would like really
like to mention that even though the
next things are interesting and they are
bringing newer results this is so easy
that it's still very much used in
different parts of our pipeline and
different and used by a lot of people so
the next thing I will go into is
character embedding and character and
bearings are kind of important because a
lot of the times your data
right so you might have a lot of unknown
terms which is which happens very often
when you have the language of students
like for instance in the first slide
when I introduced check the sentence was
everything is figure out able figure out
Abel is not and that was specifically
geared to its students it's not
something you would find in three train
vectors but it's also hard to like
there's just new kind of language that's
that's hard to always vectorize or hard
to find in your vocabulary
so nice thing about character embedding
says it takes it starts with characters
but eventually goes to go it's
eventually able to represent syllables
or parts of word which makes it less
prone to new or unknown words or our new
symbols even like when we when we are
dealing with algebra or other parts of
math or even chemistry there are
different symbols that come in which we
might not always have stored so this is
a very typical character embedding
pipeline here you take all of the single
words and then you have some word
embeddings you apply another convolution
layers with multiple filters that gives
you like a tensor like format for the
output and then you can do something
like max pooling over time or you can do
something else as well but you finally
get like a 1 1 D vector you pass it
through an LS DM and it doesn't have to
be one other stem it could be layers of
lsdm depending on what you're trying to
do and then finally you have a soft max
layer you keep running this and you you
kind of fill up the as you optimize for
the problem you're trying to solve if
it's a language model you're trying to
solve given play does is a next word
premiere you will eventually fill up the
character vectors character vectors of
play and I am bringing this up for two
reason one we have used it in several
cases where it has shown better results
than pure were two Veck but also because
in general this can
form a very good first layer to like
your your character vectors can form a
very good first layer to another
downstream and stream tasks this these
are things I have kind of discussed one
of the advantages here that I have not
discussed is that because characters are
kind of few if you were just considering
the English language plus a few special
characters your initial one-hot encoding
could be just a hundred like could be
just hundred in one dimension whereas if
you were doing it with words it could be
ten thousand which means the initial
vector is huge of course character and
bearings do require deeper networks so
that part is also there I guess here is
where using GPUs also kind of comes in a
little bit once you start doing your own
m bearings you will be storing them
somewhere which can in later on later
phases get used by other people's who
might or might not use GPUs so next
thing I will look at is sentence and
bearings this is also something we built
in house both the character and the
sentence embedding we built in house
just because it was more relevant for
the data that we had instead of
downloading data for sentence and
bedding I think tensorflow has good
pre-trained vectors which again worked
in working generalize domains quite well
so the different architectures that I
looked at was auto-encoders where you
know you take the same sentence and on
the other side you try to reproduce the
same sentence and you have a structure
in between part of which is your
sentence vector as you keep as you keep
doing like the cross-entropy
through the keep decreasing the cross
entropy you fill up your you basically
change the weight of your sentence
vectors to represent the problem it's
similar for language models you try to
predict the next word and for skipped
out vectors you try to predict the
previous sentence and the next sentence
given the current sentence I will take a
brief look into the architecture of the
sentence and bearing form so in this
particular architecture
the initial input was the tensor of the
word vectors it was fed into analyst TM
which outputted your sentence vector
which was fed into a soft Max and then
the problem we were trying to optimize
for autoencoders was the same sentence
itself for language models we were
trying to optimize the next words any
questions so far
okay cool so the next slide I'm going to
go to is thinking of word embeddings in
context so I will just read through this
comic so the morning air is getting
crisp and then the reply the other
person says wait a minute two months ago
it was all about getting burnt to a
crisp probably talking about California
but and then the next thing he says is
how come no one gets burnt to a crisp
and crispy air or once in a while the
language model comes unraveled
snap crackle flop but we we see this in
in many different examples like somebody
is very good at playing the piano and
then another sentence the child is
playing in the park you have the same
word but they mean something completely
different so if you have the typical
word tuvok representation would have the
same vector for both of them so in the
new new system what you want is you want
the vector of crisp given the context
and I started looking into this very
recently and there is this paper on deep
contextualize word representation which
got the best paper award at NaCl in 2018
so the nice saying there are several
papers in the space one of the nice
things about this formulation is that
the codes are publicly available in
Allen NLP initially it was just in the
Python framework now there is
availability in tensorflow Karason
chainer so you could basically download
it and start working with it without
worrying much I will go into a little
detail of how does it work and I have
again repeated the character embedding
slide
merely to point out that the input to
Elmo is the character embeddings similar
to what do the structure so the first
layer is a character embedding and that
goes into Elmo so so how does it
actually work it uses a bi-directional
language model which means it maximizes
the probability given play given the
Broadway what is the probability of
seeing play and Plus given premiered
yesterday what is the probability of
seeing play before it so it maximizes
both of these probabilities so that's
one thing that's different compared to
previous language models that I have
discussed the other thing is the outputs
it represents are also a little
different so one obvious output that it
gives is the last layer so this is the
information from the last layer of the
embedding but it also gives the
information from the other layers of the
embedding and what the authors have seen
is that for some problems which are
syntactic like detecting parts of speech
lower layers are more useful and for
other problems which are more semantic
like differentiating between play in the
context of playing music versus play in
the context of playing in a part the
upper layer the upper layers are more
useful they also kind of outline a way
to to use all of these layers with a
regularization factor which which is
quite interesting so before I go into
this also the way I have used maybe I
should stay in this slide the main ways
I have used this output is I've used max
pooling I've also used aggregating and
I'm looking into some other sorry max
pooling and basic averaging of the
layers and the last layer of course and
I'm also looking into some other
techniques of using all the layers
correctly I have not used weighting each
of the layers differently and figuring
out the weight from the problem at hand
mainly because most of the problems I
work with are in the realm of very small
data so it's hard to figure out weights
if you have too small data so this I say
then but it's still true now this used
to be the traditional transfer learning
pipeline you get like initially you have
some sentence going in you have some
embedding method you have a vector
representation and you have a downstream
classification start task with something
like context-aware outputs what you can
do is you can you have so this is
something that would come out of elmo
you have the initial text you have the
embedding method you get the information
on all the layers and then you can
fine-tune each of the layers depending
on the specific problem that you have
this is actually fairly common in
computer vision people when they take
different layers of imagenet to do
predictions very often they will change
the layers with some neural architecture
to make the prediction so it's something
that's almost being borrowed from
computer vision and then the next step
is aggregating very often so for
instance I have not had a lot of success
with fine tuning and it's not because it
doesn't work it's mostly because I did
not have enough data that gave me
information that gave me enough
information to change the vectors to
make a difference but aggregating is
something that almost everybody would
use because you have so many layers of
information given to you you have to
decide how you want to choose it and
then there are many different kinds of
aggregation so if I had to sum this up
in like one slide the whole process of
transfer learning initially there is a
training process if you're using
something like Elmo you get a lot of it
out of the box another reason another
thing I would say about Elmo is because
it uses character embedding it was much
more suitable to the type of data I had
where as were to back out of the box
would not basically have a lot of the
tokens that I would have in my
vocabulary you can have language models
machine translations either you
do it in house or you do it you just get
it free trained the next step which is
less pursued in NLP is use some neural
architectures to change each of the
layers it could be R n n CN NS or the
transfer a transformer model which I
haven't spoken about much and then the
final thing to do would be aggregated
which could be an averaging or a max
pool recently people are also looking at
attention models which will dynamically
allocate weights to the different layers
I also typically show this slide because
this is my pipeline where I mainly get
the training aggregate and then do the
classification on top of it having said
that I'd like to show some information
on like performance from model tuning so
this is from a blog from a company
called indigo and they have a framework
where you can go and benchmark your
transfer learning your transfer learning
vectors against their data and they have
shown that with AZ as you have more and
more training data fine tuning the fine
tuning the vectors gives you more
information I think this is useful and
this will be used more and more as the
as this paradigm becomes more how should
I put it as this becomes more normalized
in some sense or more standardized like
people actually know what are the best
ways to tune the layers before going
into aggregation so talk a little bit
again about democratization so far I've
mainly spoken about how do you build the
vectors so having transfer learning you
can think anybody can take advantage of
the deep learning even if they have
small data again feature engineering is
kind of taken care off in this space and
also like this once you have the results
you store it in a redshift or anywhere
else where you're any remote team around
the world could pull the data and create
a model without knowing much
so before I go into applications any
questions yes how does that address the
problem so maybe I should have put an
output of the probably don't have I do
not have necessarily I should have put a
slide on the output what happens is you
have this sentence the Broadway play
premiered yesterday the output even for
a single layer would be a tensor which
would represent there would be a word
vector but it would be a tensor for this
sentence so play let's say you have
another sentence which is the boy is
playing in the park that would be a
different vector like that tensor
representation would be different so you
would have to give the entire sentence
and the output vector would be one set
of numbers you give another sentence
which is the boy is playing in the park
your output vector will be another set
of vectors so if you look at play in
sentence one and if you look at play in
sentence two the word vectors are
different and they are different because
of that particular context does that
make it somewhat it is it is directed
towards a sentence so the final output
is it could be more than a sentence you
could put two sentence in it as well but
it is mostly optimized for a sentence so
you put in a sentence and you get like
the word vector is out of it maybe we
can talk about it more
so in the space of applications the
first thing I'll talk about is creating
a knowledge base which we've been quite
successful with most of our data the
other things you're looking at is
finding unique concepts and in some
applications it's particularly important
and the ones that are in gray are things
that are more in progress or things we
are sort of exploring with different
kinds of different kinds of techniques
and some things here like Auto creating
flashcards would be like a really good
product application for us or helping
tutors or expert answers with relevant
material these would have quite a bit of
impact so what does what do I mean by
creating knowledge base so we have all
of the contents at one level we have the
different subjects it could be algebra
physics
statistics mechanical engineering and so
on and we have several tens of subjects
then within each subject you have within
each subject you have like further
drilling down so you could let let me
let's say I go into statistics you have
some high level clusters probability
testing regression and then you keep
going down there you go keep going down
inside probability discrete probability
distributions you can go down binomial
voice over discrete probability
distribution so basically you create
KnowledgeTree and then you tag all of
your content with different nodes in the
tree in some cases this has been treated
as as a multi-class problem with with
regular like classification
so the typical pipeline that we followed
was you get the sentence and bearings
from you get the sentence and bearings
from the pipeline that I showed you
concatenate the ELMO m bearings well and
that requires some aggregation before
you can't catenate it we add a tf-idf
weighting and that is very specific to
the data type that we have a lot of the
times we do get repeatedly students
saying please help or I have a test and
we kind of want to down weight those
sentences because that does not give us
any
Meishan about the subject matter so the
tf-idf helps with that quite a bit and
then on top of it we throw like a simple
classifier a lot of the time logistic
regression because then we can hand it
over to the engineering team or anybody
to work with it we find Union results
based on classic things precision recall
upon scores and given depending on
specific product needs for instance in
some product needs it was very important
to be right it was okay like false
positives were not okay
so we tuned it to its high precision and
it varies depending on what the
knowledge base is being used for I would
also like to mention the transfer
learning is not the only thing we use
it's it's a fairly complex process one
of the things that has been very useful
here and I won't talk about it but it's
weak supervision where basically you
write rules to generate training data
and that's just to augment the small
amount of annotated data that we have on
average we were able to achieve more
than 80% accuracy for the different
nodes in the knowledge base and we have
just started working with flash cards
and the flash cards domain what happens
is let's one of the things we want to
know is what are like the dominating
topics or dominating themes or concepts
that that are represented by a term for
instance if you type cardiac muscle and
if you try to search for all the flash
cards that are available you get like a
range of topics someone will say this is
striated muscles of the heart then there
are other concepts like musculoskeletal
then some other cards say propels blood
so one of the goals has been to find the
number of unique concepts this is in
general not easy because a lot of the
times there might be just one card with
a different concept but we try to find
the dominating concepts in general
another thing that I've just started
looking at is word sense disambiguation
particularly since the contextualize
word vectors promised to work very well
in the space and this again has to do
with
like if you search for pleated sheet I
I'm not a bio person at all but my my
obvious answer was cloth curtain or
something in that space or there's
something in dancing as well but pleated
sheet is a regular secondary structure
in proteins
so trying to December grade these
typically this is not hard because
usually a student will come and you can
gain enough information to figure out
that they want bio but sometimes there
are terms within a subject that can mean
different things so this is fairly
important another example is circular
it's a mathematical concept but it's
also store advertisement it's a
direction we are looking at another
direction that we've started looking at
specially with character embeddings is
extracting equations
so when student ask questions there will
be and I think it was there in the
example as well that equations are typed
in very different ways so just to find
what equations are being represented it
also helps to know it kind of binds so
equations are there in like online
tutoring they're there in flashcards
check study but it there's also math
solver so it helps us bind all the
products together and finally I will say
like talk about democratizing I hope in
phase two so it's something like the
knowledge base creation we basically
tagged all the content and we have a
structured knowledge base like basically
that's an SQL their table that can be
queried by anybody so if someone kind of
asks you know how much what percent is
your first statistics data isn't
probability you can write an SQL query
and give an answer so this makes this
this information available for report
generation for bi tasks and others it's
also like this is kind of this also
feeds into building recommendation
systems for match one of the things he
said during my introduction was matching
tutors and students so when students
come in they will write the text and
once they are tagged on line with what
the subtopics are it helps a
recommendation system point the students
to as the right tutors and
I think I will reiterate the same point
in real life most problems are small
data problems and transfer learning kind
of replaces feature engineering to a
certain extent which makes it really
cool the other thing that is also
interesting when you're using transfer
there are vectors as features is you
might have additional features like
views clicks conversion rates which
could go into the same model and produce
something better so you have the option
of augmenting it with structured
features that's it one more thing I I
would mention is in NLP we have not
explored like the whole contextual word
embedding as much as people have in
computer vision so there there are
studies there are papers and computer
vision which kind of says like why does
transfer learning work those kind of
works are on the way and I think like in
a few years probably NOP will be at a
point where it can use like all the
context all the different layers more
effectively than what we're doing today
thank you yes I know so Elmo I only
started working it on it like two months
ago maybe so I mean we were doing fairly
well with in-house built were built
representation of sentences and
characters as well Elmo does improve the
process
it's also possible like if you just look
at the elmo architecture it's not that
hard to write it yourself and caris and
something else but I wouldn't since it's
already there and it has shown
improvement mmm I haven't there's also
you LM fit which is in the same space
and this is also like another direction
that we are exploring that
what other what other packages exist in
the space yes
oh no corpus is not small sorry I
probably should have the label data is
very small so the number of data that is
tagged as probability is very small but
the corpus is huge
what's your question like what the size
of the label data is pretty small I
would say for something like probability
which is a pretty large cluster I would
have like 200 to 300 but a cluster like
regression would have like hundred it
was it's kind of complex it's not
necessarily on each of the clusters so
it would be sometimes it would be
multiple multi class labeling so inside
each of the clusters it would be multi
class labeling but for the level of
probability testing and regression it
was against each of the clusters that's
right
[Music]
we don't so how should I put it so
you're saying if the tutor did not
answer correctly yeah we we do have data
on that kind of work where if you were
looking for pleated sheet and if you'd
like there are search logs and things
like that that gives an idea of you know
what the student found and what they did
not find also for check study where the
expert is answering offline there are
measures to see satisfaction of the
students the part where it's a little
tricky is where it's online tutoring
sometimes people are on videos there is
like maybe a little bit of chat but the
chap might not cover the entire content
in that case we typically rely on
reviews and if the students are not
satisfied typically they'll write a bad
review and you could say like a medium
experience is very hard to detect
because people don't write a review in a
medium experience but yeah
so that's how I created the sentence
vectors so the skip thought vectors and
I have the architecture of the skip skip
thought vectors in the appendix but the
Skip taught vector is basically predict
this sentence given the sentence around
it and in the final classification have
used both the sentence vectors and the
context vectors because the context
vectors alone did not give as high
accuracy tangent in a without the
sentence vectors
sure what Oh
okay so so so if you look at this
knowledge-based structure we so when I
think in in this term we actually
classify the data as what subject it
belongs to and then we go and classify
underneath it what sub subject it
belongs to so we kind of we also ask the
student for the subjects a lot of the
time they're not correct so we cannot
totally depend on it
so we kind of go in a hierarchical
fashion so in principle we should know
that if this is a PD in math or physics
having said that a PD in math and
physics the question could be very
similar right that's possible in that
case it's very easy to get it wrong and
most of the questions that are not
detected accurately are in that very
Confucian zone where the language is so
similar that it's very hard to
disambiguate yes yeah
any more questions
[Applause]